good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored today marks 1
month since Hamas terrorists invaded
Israel and butchered more than 1400
people now October the 7th is destined
to become a date we never forget like
911 its morbid memories will echo
through history but as Israelis today
look back in anger and in grief the rest
of the world's beginning to contemplate
what else that date will come to
represent would it plunge the Middle
East into a deadly wider crisis will the
simmering racial resentment caus
bitterness and blood across the world
will it nail the coffin of a two-state
solution prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has given his first answer to
the big question of what happens to Gaza
when the war is over and frankly it's a
major cause of concern Israel will
for an indefinite period will have the
overall uh security
responsibility this means Netanyahu
plans to effectively occupy Gaza
completely for an indefinite period long
after the bombing of Bloodshed is done
that to me is a massive error of
judgment Hamas says more than 10,000
Palestinians are already dead since
October the 7th as 10,000 grieving
families who will blame Israel and
Netanyahu for destroying their lives and
as a bombing intensifies their Fury and
Malice will surely spread there will be
no safe or Fair Way for the Palestinian
people to live under an Israeli heel no
path to peace net Netanyahu must surely
know this last night I asked Israeli
president Isaac Herzog if Netanyahu
himself is now a barrier to peace he
gave a diplomatic answer that was I
would say far from a ringing
indorsement the day after the war will
come where all these issues will be
discussed we are a vibrant democracy we
don't shy away from anything but right
now we're all United we are all United
in one goal we must return the hostages
back we must overcome and Prevail
against our enemies and we must bring
bring peace and security to our borders
and our peoples this is my only aim at
this point and I get it Israel's focused
on wiping out Hamas after what they did
to their people on October the 7th but
what happens next will change the course
of history Palestinians need new leaders
who accept a Jewish State Israel needs a
new leader who recognizes that
Palestinians too deserve a state and the
same human rights as Israelis Netanyahu
has honestly divided to rule he propped
up Hamas to split the pal Palestinians
with now catastrophic consequences now
he's making Aur calls for more lengthy
occupation when tensions couldn't be
higher I don't know frankly who should
control Gaza when Hamas or if Hamas is
wiped out but I do know it can't be
Benjamin
Netanyahu well my first guest tonight
was a guest of promis of Netanyahu in
Israel early this year when he was fated
as the most prominent Iranian to visit
Israel in history the exiled Crown
Prince prince of Iran Resa palvi joins
me now from Washington DC uh great to
see you uh Crown Prince I really
appreciate you joining the program I've
interviewed you several times over the
years in different circumstances so it's
great to have you on uncensor for the
first time first of all your reaction
was good I'm sorry sorry good to talk to
you again Pierce after about 12 years I
think last time we spoke it is when I
was it is it's good to see you um let me
ask you first of all your reaction we're
a month in now to the Israel Hamas War
what is your reaction to What has been
going
on Pierce I think that the world cannot
ignore the elephant in the room and that
is since the rise of uh radical Islam as
a result of the Iranian Revolution that
took my country Hostage to begin with
and has since forment this kind of of uh
antagonism Regional instability
warmongering uh supporting terrorist
groups and what have you we should not
really be surprised that at the tail end
we are faced with this kind of uh R
rises in tension and I think it's uh
it's telling that you know we have to
cure the disease ultimately and until
and we don't put an end at the ideology
itself I don't think we can really be
hopeful to have legitimate peace in the
region for the best interest of the
people living there and of course beyond
our region how it impacts the rest of
the world yesterday I interviewed the
president of Israel Isaac Herzog I know
you met him as well as prime minister
Netanyahu on your historic visit to
Israel and he said this about
Iran there's an Empire of evil from tan
emanating with a whole culture of hate
to eradicate all of
us would you agree with with
that look I think uh president Herzog uh
prime minister Netanyahu and I think
along with that many leaders and Beyond
leaders people in the world who by now
have hosted in their respective
countries in the west and elsewhere
Iranians who were forced to flee the
country as a result of this regime to
understand that what the Iranian people
are like and want is totally different
that that that the regime in tan and
I've always asked for uh uh the world
Community including media when they talk
about Iran to specify that they are
talking about the regime in Iran not the
people of Iran so when we say Iran I
want to make clear that this is not the
Iranian people you're talking about
about the regime that's very important
as a distinction because I think that
while the problem correctly emanates
from tan and I've been saying this all
these years that the eye of the octopus
is in fact in tan and we are are busy
fighting the tentacles without putting
out the Beast itself of course uh in
that statement I think is correct the
question however is how can this change
come about and there's a lot to discuss
about this matter well there is and of
course Central to this right now is the
war against Hamas a terror group who've
been in charge of Gaza for 17 years or
so um really ran a repressive regime of
their own against their own their own
people continued to treat Palestinian
civilians
as just some kind of military Capital
that can be expended on a whim it seems
um and everyone who saw what happen
October the 7th who has an ounce of
humanity will completely understand why
Israel is going so hard now for Hamas
but the problem for The Wider world and
certainly for The Wider Arab Community
is that in trying to eradicate Hamas who
who live amongst civilians there are
thousands and thousands of completely
innocent
often children half of the casualties
are reported to be children being killed
in the process uh is there a moral
equivalence here is there a line that
Israel shouldn't Cross or is this idea
that they should be proportionate just
for the birds if you're in a war and
you're trying to wipe out a terror
group well again the the principal
funding and the principal support that
comes to these groups must have a money
Trail and a source in terms of uh what's
keeping them uh going uh it's not a
secret that the regime in Teran has been
behind most of these groups has financed
them has armed them has used them at
proxies to advance their agenda in the
region with the ultimate goal of
exporting an ideology and force the
world into assimilation under a modern
de caliphate this is not simply in the
region Pierce mind you today we hear
this ominous sound of radical islamists
who are trying to shape a different
future for countries even in Europe
hoping to gain a majority and force uh
uh the laws to change uh in the way they
want to see the the the world govern
under this kind of uh caliphate this is
really a challenge that faces all of us
it's not just an issue to Israel having
to deal with the problem of having being
attacked by a terrorist group it is the
nature of the Beast itself as I said
it's a disease that needs to be cured
and while you can deal with the symptoms
if the Cure is not found and in my
opinion The Cure is to put an end to
what is the source behind this extremism
this radicalism the problem will never
um uh dissipate one has to do what they
have to do sometimes wrong sometimes
it's a moral issue as you pointed but
that doesn't solve the ultimate problem
I believe that the sooner we solve the
root cause of the problem all of these
issues will ultimately find a way to
find a proper resolution with every uh
interest of uh humanitarian and
Liberties of all people Israelis
Palestinians Arabs Iranians and the
whole world we have to work together
with the problem and not you know uh uh
Kick the Can down the road and and hope
that by Miracle the problem is going to
dissipate it's not going to do you have
any doubt that Iran was behind what
happened on October the 7th in terms of
the scale of it in terms of the quantity
of of you know Firepower that they took
over the Border I mean does it look to
you like an Iran sponsored
operation well I think that uh hours
after the attack there were already some
Palestinian Banner that were hanging on
some public buildings in tan and a short
visit thereafter uh of uh Iran's
officials uh with Hamas Representatives
this simply is not a coincidence it must
have been in some form or shape planned
or anticipated and in fact they haven't
denied the fact Hamas itself has had
thanked officially one of their uh
representative I saw a clip somewhere
where he actually acknowledges the
support coming from tan so uh they're
not denying it and uh and I think that's
a fact that is hardly contested by
anyone who understand enough about the
Quagmire uh in the Middle East and and
Iran having been The Godfather of
terrorism all these years final question
we've seen Isis pretty well wiped out
we've seen Al-Qaeda severely diminished
in its ability to operate if Israel was
to be successful in eradicating Hamas uh
and affected regime change in Gaza could
you see this spilling over potentially
to regime change in Iran and if if it
did would you be Keen to go back there
and assume the power that was removed
from you in
1979 well pierce my formula for Chang in
Iran is of course based on popular
sovereignty and the Free Will of the
Iranian people that can only choose
their future once liberated from this
regime that denies them the right to
freely Choose Or elect whoever they want
in the future my process for change in
Iran is to make sure that we have a
democratic transition post regime
collapse that we can have a constituent
assembly When people's Representatives
will debate what will be the best course
for the country in the future to offer
the Iranian people by referendum a
chance to ratify the proposed
Constitution hopefully based on the
universal Declaration of Human Rights
which are clear you know separation of
church from State and it is for the
Iranian people to ultimately V their
choice I'm not running for any office or
having any other uh ambition in in mind
other than to serve that process and be
a facilitator for that process and speak
on behalf of all Iranians for their
right to choose and freely determine
their their future I do however believe
that the solution in Iran is regime
change and this regime will never change
its Behavior which is why in 40 Years of
trying the the the the biggest problem
and flaw in Western policy foreign
policy Vis Iran was an expectation of
behavior change this regime's DNA
doesn't along with the values that
Iranians cherish that is also cherished
in free countries human rights equality
putting an end to any form of
discrimination so at the end of the day
we need to make sure that people in the
world if they truly want to help the
process of stability and and democracy
and freedom to be on the side of the
Iranian people and forget about
continuing to negotiate with a regime
that has never had any intentions to
reform itself the time has come for
change at the ask of the Iranian people
people and therefore I think the world
has a golden opportunity to use the best
allies they have in the process as the
instrument of change the Iranian people
themselves but they cannot fight alone
we need to have support from the uh
Coalition of the Willing in free
societies and people who do uh Champion
democracy and human rights but one word
answer if you got the opportunity
democratically would you go back and
Lead
Iran I will help uh my fellow compatriot
as much as I can with no personal
ambition I I don't think that uh uh the
issue for me is anything beyond helping
the creation of the kind of Institutions
well well beyond the Constitution and
government because Civil Society is the
ultimate Watchdog for society and we
need to strengthen this institution to
make democracy a lasting system in a
country okay I'll take that as a yes not
76 words
rer no I I will I will help any way that
I can of of course if the opportunity
present itself it's good to talk to you
again thank you very much indeed for
joining me Resa palvi thank you very
much thank you
pierce